what's going on guys any longtime viewer
of our show knows that our correspondent
Nick Mundy has a very special
relationship with action superstar
Dwayne the rock Johnson screen junkies
my name is Nick Mundy don't this up I
doubt that counted I'm glad we did this
I'm glad we're friends we're getting
best friends don't look at me okay look
acknowledge it I'll make it a weird okay
right here we go what started out as one
super fans obsession has blossomed into
a full-blown bromance
they even tweet at each other we sent
Nick to interview his best friend at the
junket for his new movie San Andreas but
what Nick doesn't know is that he's in
for a life-changing surprise so let's
throw it over to our very special
correspondent the rock alright hey guys
dwayne johnson here and I am here to
surprise my good buddy my main man my G
Nick Mundy I have teamed up with all my
buddies at screen junkies teamed up with
his amazing and beautiful fiance Dallara
and we are going to prank it forward in
ways that we're gonna raise the bar in
terms of pranking it forward this is
gonna be amazing
today I am going to marry Nick Mundy let
me clarify to his fiance right now Nick
thinks that we had this whole other bit
planned up yes elaborate bit that we
didn't do we got here and he found out
that the bit was not happening so right
now he and Andi are upstairs scrambling
to find a new bit to do you're gonna put
those on yeah you don't need to put on
the American flag pants desperate
measures I'm telling you
uh life's falling apart trying to come
up with other ideas I'm working now were
you shocked when the rock said yeah I'll
do it
he didn't just say yeah I'll do it like
originally we said like hey do you want
to be in it yeah and he was like I want
to do the ceremony so the rock uh filete
his paperwork in was ordained this is a
marriage document the marriage license
everything is completely legal there's a
notary public present can you smell what
The Rock is officiating a wedding
Nick's up on the roof getting ready to
pitch our new ideas to the rocks team
but Nick doesn't realize that no matter
what bit we pitch the rocks teams
they're not going to think it's funny
the big thing that we're gonna do we're
just gonna shoot on that camera is hey
okay so you say people will give us
friends will you save me if I drown in a
pool and then I just jumped into it as
it is he's running behind and he's got a
good room in the 48 so I think was gonna
be betters I think it sucks but I think
we just roll this over
no harm right yeah yeah it happens and
we'll talk soon about them yeah the
Dover just great ever
right thank you
I'm sorry dude
okay we're nothing better you think you
ruin the relationship I hope not don't
say that I just feel like drop a ball
and like you know this was the fourth
one each one has to get better and I
would I don't blame him I don't blame if
we're not doing why are we still
recording like look at this episode
gonna be a thumbnail to me crying we
just got the text from Andy he's on his
way downstairs with Nick they're gonna
stop right outside the door to where we
are right now and then the rocks gonna
walk out and surprise him this is a
total surprise I wonder how long it's
gonna take him to realize exactly what's
happening all right
just come over by this door and give me
one last stand up I hate cilantro just
come give me I want you to start we're
gonna trying to salvage this right give
me other give me a walkout I don't want
to do that just give me something okay
we decided that we're going to wait to
do it right as otherwise just nothing
else was good so see in a few weeks
what what I do man battles how are you
good
great thank you very much every [ __ ] is
good yeah sorry about the victim we're
totally okay for listen
what's good so a little surprise for you
huh just when you thought the day was
gonna be terrible yeah actually he's
gonna be the greatest day I got
megapanza pleasure for me to do this
it's an honor for me to do this
completely legal I am officially
ordained by the state of California yeah
I go all out
Wow yeah because you're my bestie oh man
thanks dude
so you're gonna have to sign these see
you sign right there what so I think
it's time for you to get married all
right cool Deb are home ready to this
I'm gonna I'm gonna walk you down the
aisle
you
dearly beloved we are gathered here
today in the presence of our family and
friends to witness and celebrate the
coming together of Nikolas Monday and
Dilara Carabas nothing is more powerful
than your union it carries more force
than a bolt of lightning or even the
world's largest earthquake much like the
ones you'll see in San Andreas oh and
everybody's Gators makes me knife thank
you very much
hold your applause you see it 3d okay
too much it's too much right now I
believe the bride and the groom have
prepared vows Nick I promise to always
love you and be there for you no matter
what
I'm excited to spend the rest of our
lives together I love you dummy you're
my best friend my day I met you was the
first in my life I can't wait to spend
the rest of all with you love you so
much I can't wait to do weird stuff with
you for the rest of our Dallara
you take Nick to be your husband to love
honor and cherish holding only to him
from this day on I do Nick
you take Dallara to be your wife to love
honor and cherish holding only to her
and not to the rock
from this day on I knew this is cool
thank you because it's real by the power
vested in me playing the rock Johnson
ordained by the state of California and
he almighty universe itself and now
pronounce you husband and wife
Nick you may kiss ladies and gentlemen I
am proud to introduce mr. and mrs. Nick
Monday
Olivia
thank you guys so much for everything I
love you all or the most let's get drunk
he didn't bully crap big thanks to
Dwayne the rock Johnson our friends at
Warner Brothers and everyone who helped
put this magical event together be sure
to check out San Andreas in theaters on
May 29th and congratulations mr. and
mrs. Nick Mundy bye-bye